A BRAZEN AND VIOLENT ASSAULT,
PAUL PELOSI, THE HUSBAND OF
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI,
BRUTALIZED IN THEIR HOME.
THE POLICE SAY THIS ATTACK
HAPPENED OVERNIGHT AFTER THE MAN
BROKE IN.
THE SPEAKER WAS IN WASHINGTON.
HER 82-YEAR-OLD HUSBAND IS IN
THE HOSPITAL, THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE SAYS TO MAKE A FULL
RECOVERY.
A POLICE BRIEFING IS SCHEDULED
FOR THIS HOUR.
AT THIS MOMENT WE'RE TRYING TO
FILL IN THE BIG QUESTION, WHAT
WAS THE MOTIVE?
THE MALE SUSPECT IS IN CUSTODY.
SOURCES TELLING CNN THE AS
ASSAILANT USED A HAMMER TO BEAT
MR. PELOSI.
WE'RE JOINED WITH IMPORTANT
BREAKING NEWS.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> Reporter: JOHN, IT APPEARS WE
MAY ACTUALLY HAVE THE MOTIVE OR
PART OF THE MOTIVE.
I WAS TOLD BY A SOURCE BRIEFED
ON THE ATTACK THAT THE ASSAY
LAPT WHO TALKED PAUL PELOSI WAS
ACTU
ACTUALLY IN SEARCH FOR SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE, NANCY PELOSI.
THAT BEFORE THE ASSAULT
OCCURRED, IN OTHER WORDS, BEFORE
HE ATTACKED PELOSI, THE INTRUDER
CONFRONTED HIM SAYING, WHERE IS
NANCY, WHERE IS NANCY?
JOHN, THIS IS FROM A SOURCE WHO
WAS BRIEFED ON THE ATTACK, WHO
SAYS BEFORE HE PHYSICALLY
ASSAULTED THE SPEAKER'S HUSBAND,
HE WAS CLEARLY LOOKING FOR
PELOSI HERSELF.
QUOTE, WHERE IS NANCY?
WHERE IS NANCY?
JOHN?
>> JAMIE GANGEL JOINING US.
I WANT TO BRING IN EN PEREZ.
YOU'VE BEEN TRACKING WHAT POLICE
ARE LEARNING.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THIS INVESTIGATION AND ABOUT
THIS BRAZEN, VIOLENT ASSAULT?
>> JOHN, WE KNOW NOW THAT THE
FBI IS STILL AT THE SCENE THERE
AT THE PELOSI HOME IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
OF COURSE, THIS HAPPENED IN THE
EARLY MORNING HOURS.
IF THE SPEAKER HAD BEEN THERE,
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN A SECURITY
DETAIL FROM THE U.S. CAPITOL
POLICE.
THEY WERE NOT THERE BECAUSE SHE
IS NOT -- SHE WAS NOT AT HOME.
THEY GOT THERE VERY QUICKLY.
AND NOW WE'RE TOLD THAT THIS IS
AN INVESTIGATION BEING DONE
JOINTLY BY THE FBI WITH THE
CAPITOL POLICE AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
OF COURSE, THE BIG QUESTION THAT
I THINK JAMIE IS BEGINNING TO
HELP ANSWER IS WHY THE FBI WOULD
BE INVOLVED AND THIS, PERHAPS,
MIGHT EXPLAIN IT.
IF THE ASSAILANT WAS TRYING TO
CARRY OUT THIS ATTACK IN SEARCH
OF THE SPEAKER, IF THERE WAS
SOME KIND OF POLITICAL
MOTIVATION, PERHAPS, THOSE WOULD
BE THE REASONS WHY THE FBI WOULD
BE PLAYING A BIG ROLE IN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
AGAIN, WE'RE EXPECTING TO HEAR A
LOT MORE FROM THE POLICE AT THIS
BRIEFING IN -- LATER THIS HOUR.
IT DOES BEGIN TO SORT OF HELP
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS.
THEY KNOW WHO CARRIED OUT THIS
ATTACK.
THEY'RE DOING THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
AND THEY'RE GETTING A SENSE OF
WHAT BROUGHT HIM -- THIS PERSON
TO THE HOME.
IT IS A MALE PERSON WHO WAS
ARRESTED THERE OR DETAINED BY
THE POLICE.
STILL A LOT OF QUESTIONS AS TO
HOW HE GOT INTO THE HOUSE.
IT APPEARS THAT HE CAME IN
THROUGH THE BACK OF THE
RESIDENCE AND THEN CARRIED OUT
THIS ATTACK.
A LOT OF VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS STILL AS TO WHAT
BROUGHT HIM TO THAT LOCATION,
JOHN.
>> EVAN, STAND BY AS WELL, I
WANT TO CIRCLE BACK TO JAMIE
GANGEL.
EVAN MAKES A KEY POINT THAT HAD
THE SPEAKER BEEN HOME IN SAN
FRANCISCO, THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN
A CAPITOL SECURITY POLICE DETAIL
THERE BECAUSE THAT'S
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE AND THE FBI ON THE
SCENE SIGNALS THIS IS NOT JUST A
SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
INVESTIGATION.
SO YOU CAN PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL DETAILS, I WANT TO
CIRCLE BACK.
YOU SAY YOU'VE BEEN BRIEFED BY
SOMEBODY FAMILIAR WITH THE EARLY
STAGE OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
SHARE MORE.
>> Reporter: JOHN, WE HAVE ALL
BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT VIOLENCE
AND THREATS RELATED TO POLITICS.
WE DON'T KNOW YET WHAT THE
COMPLETE MOTIVE IS HERE, BUT
I'VE JUST BEEN TOLD FROM A
SOURCE WHO WAS BRIEFED ON THE
ATTACK THAT THE ASSAILANT WHO
ATTACKED PAUL PELOSI, THE
SPEAKER'S HUSBAND, WAS IN SEARCH
FOR THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
THAT BEFORE THE ASSAULT
OCCURRED, BEFORE HE PHYSICALLY
STARTED ATTACKING PAUL PELOSI,
THAT HE CAME INTO THE HOME
SHOUTING, QUOTE, WHERE IS NANCY?
WHERE IS NANCY?
SO, THERE DOES SEEM TO BE SOME
INDICATION THAT, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER THIS WAS POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED, YOU KNOW, AND WHAT
THE POLITICS MIGHT HAVE BEEN,
THOSE ARE STILL QUESTIONS TO BE
ANSWERED, BUT IT DOES CERTAINLY
SOUND LIKE HE WAS LOOKING FOR
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
JOHN?
>> JAMIE GANGEL, THANK YOU FOR
THE BREAKING NEWS REPORT.
EVAN PEREZ, TO COME BACK TO YOU,
TO THE POINT YOU JUST MADE.
LET'S ELABORATE TO MAKE CLEAR.
FEDERAL INVOLVEMENT, THIS IS A
VERY DIFFERENT INVESTIGATION, A
VERY DIFFERENT FOCUS.
IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
BREAK-IN ON A HIGH-PROFILE HOME,
AIMED AT PAUL PELOSI OR A RANDOM
BREAK-IN VERSUS IF THE FBI IS
GETTING CLUES TO BACK UP JAMIE'S
REPORTING THAT THIS WAS A
TARGETED ATTACK ON THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
>> EXACTLY, JOHN.
THE FACT WE SEE THE FBI, THEY'RE
STILL THERE, BY THE WAY, TELLS
US THEY'RE GOING TO PLAY A BIG
ROLE IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
THEY DON'T NORMALLY DO THIS ON
JUST AN ASSAULT ON A RANDOM HOME
OR EVEN IF IT'S SOME RANDOM
ATTACK.
THERE HAS TO BE SOME EVIDENCE
THEY'VE GOTTEN FROM THE EARLY
PARTS OF THIS INVESTIGATION THAT
INDICATES THEY HAVE SOME KIND OF
JURIS
JURISDICTION, SOME FEDERAL N
NEXUS.
AS JAMIE JUST SAID, THERE'S BEEN
CONCERN BY THE FBI, BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ABOUT THREATS
TO POLITICAL FIGURES IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE'VE SEEN AN ATTEMPTED
ASSASSINATION OF A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
WE'VE SEEN CONCERNS FROM THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO THREATS AT
PUBLIC OFFICIALS AT SCHOOL
BOARDS, SO ON.
THERE'S BEEN THIS SORT OF
ATMOSPHERE THAT THE FBI HAS BEEN
VERY MUCH CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TONE OF SOME OF THE RHETORIC
THAT IS DRIVING SOME OF THIS AND
SO, AGAIN, THAT'S THE BACK DROP
OF WHY THE FBI IS THERE, WHY
THEY'RE THERE VERY QUICKLY AND
WHY THEY'RE NOW PLAYING A MAJOR
ROLE IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
WE'LL LEARN MORE, OF COURSE,
FROM POLICE WHEN THEY GIVE THIS
BRIEFING, BUT KEEP IN MIND, THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE TRAVELING
WITH A SECURITY DETAIL.
THE CAPITOL POLICE GOT THERE
VERY QUICKLY BECAUSE THEY ARE
PRESENT IN SAN FRANCISCO JUST
FOR WHEN SHE TRAVELS TO THAT
LOCATION.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS, THE
THREATS AGAINST PUBLIC OFFICIALS
IS RISING.
IT IS A BIG CONCERN FOR THE FBI.
>> EVAN PEREZ, GRATEFUL AS WELL.
LET'S CONTINUE THE COVERAGE.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS PRESIDENT
BIDEN CALLED SPEAKER PELOSI TO
SHARE HIS OUTRAGE AT THE ATTACK
AND VOICE HIS SUPPORT NOW AS HER
HUSBAND IS HOSPITALIZED.
THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE BELIEVES
HE'LL MAKE A COMPLETE RECOVERY.
MANU RAJU IS HERE WITH ME IN
STUDIO.
FOR MORE ON WHAT WE KNOW AND THE
STUNNED REACTION HERE IN
WASHINGTON.
>> WE KNOW -- WE'RE LEARNING A
LITTLE MORE PIECE BY PIECE
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THIS
MORNING.
WE DO KNOW THIS INDIVIDUAL WHEN
HE BROKE INTO THE PELOSI HOME,
IT HAPPENED IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT, 2:27 A.M., ACCORDING TO
THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE, CAME
IN THROUGH THE BACK DOOR OF THE
HOUSE AND HAD A HAMMER IN HIS
HAND, GOING INTO THE PELOSI
HOUSE, ATTACKED MR. PELOSI WITH
A HAMMER, WAS SUPPOSEDLY TAKEN
TO THE HOSPITAL.
MR. PELOSI, QUOTE, IS EXPECTED
TO MAKE A FULL RECOVERY AND
RECEIVING EXCELLENT MEDICAL
CARE.
WE'RE LEARNING MONTH ARE ABOUT
THAT.
IT'S SO KEY TO POINT OUT ABOUT
THE SECURITY DETAIL AND THE
SECURITY SITUATION ITSELF
BECAUSE SHE TRAVELS WITH U.S.
CAPITOL POLICE BUT IT DOES NOT
EXTEND TO THE FAMILY MEMBERS
THEMSELVES.
WE HAVE SEEN THROUGH THE COURSE
OF THIS LAST COUPLE OF YEARS,
ALL THIS POLITICAL VIOLENCE
DIRECTED TOWARDS MEMBERS OF
CONGRATULATIONS WHO HAVE HAD TO
BOOST THEIR OWN SECURITY.
THEY'RE NOT PROVIDED SECURITY AS
WELL, BUT THEY ARE ALLOWED TO
SPEND FEDERAL DOLLARS TO ENHANCE
SECURITY.
THAT'S A NEW DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE
OF THE RISE OF THREATS NOW THAT
WE'RE SEEING ALSO AGAINST FAMILY
MEMBERS THEMSELVES.